we just saw the ant-man and wasp and boy
I scooped crash I think this is finally
where like yeah Marvel my past its way I
don't it had to happen sometime yeah I
mean it's okay you know we're lying it's
it's great I should say this okay just
kind of give you an idea where we're
coming from I didn't know you felt this
way to ml is like one of my top five
favorite Marvel films some people look
at me like I'm crazy but and I can't
believe I just really know I've I've
been saying this for a while nothing
against the Avengers age of Ultron some
people hate it
some people I'm just very much like
that's alright in infinity war I really
enjoy like but you got all these big
ones and I'm just like a lot of my top 5
it's just like guardians of the galaxy
hmm ant-man I really liked Thor Ragnarok
like my Panther but the kind of
standalone one yeah the standalone ones
in like outside like Black Panther felt
pretty epic Thor Ragnarok kind of filled
epic but also felt like a cheesy 80s but
Laza yeah it's a lot of these little
side stories that I like the most well
in this one in many respects feels like
someone see us as a good thing or as
someone see us a bad thing I see is a
good thing this feels the most Side
Story like oh yeah this is pretty much
this is I complete this it's almost
completely independent of everything
else that's going on they just
referenced yeah like you were in Germany
fighting in Captain America so I'm glad
they did reference that but the fight
thing is that it's still like the way
they work within they work around it is
so enjoyable and so funny yeah it's such
a funny continuing joke it does work
into kind of the style which is the
style really this is a slapstick comedy
disguised as a Marvel action this is
what's up doc and with that's another
couple that I love like capita like
Civil War I think is really good and
Winter Soldier I think is really good
but there is something about like in
this film is I was watching it was like
this is the Marvel I love where it's
like I
really feel like I'm just watching a
comic book come to life with all its
stupid science techno babble and it's
bright colors and it's like fun and
helping them build shit like it is just
so it's so reminds me of like that kind
of old-school comic feel words anything
goes it's just crazy time you know with
like the ants helping them build things
I was like I could just see this in the
panel from like a comic book from like
the 60s or 70s or even like you know the
80s and I it's what I know this is my
wheelhouse like this is what I enjoy and
to me next to prime my favorites powers
have all the Marvel characters that I
love the Spider Man like just imagine
yes a killing what be the coolest
superhero thais waiting around like
spider-man it's the coolest want to meet
but the second coolest is probably this
and so funny cuz I hate shrinking movies
I don't get into them I think they're
kind of dolls it is one of the few
really that you're at you're big you're
small you're big you're small you can
use it in an action sequence and now you
add flight on top of them then you add
this character that can you know sort of
go through things and then become solid
and can become invisible and stuff I
mean it's like adding those other
elements to it just makes it so much fun
and that you remind me a lot of the a
lot of the action scenes in this remind
me of the one good scene everyone likes
from Matrix Reloaded the highway chase
everybody a lot of that but I thought
it's more comedy you can't more joy to
it one like one of the one of the
criticism if pardon me my voice is like
kind of going in and out but one of the
criticisms of the movie what few there
are I think is they're like oh yeah
that's a good movie it's too complicated
though I have a single problem following
any of this I don't know I don't know
what people are saying like why it's too
complicated but the one eyeball on it
just that there was one point in this
movie where I did actually question for
a second I'm like what are the good guys
trying to tell you there was one moment
but then we get to them like oh you have
to do it again without yeah no way to my
dad they're they're going after a
certain Karenina trying to find certain
character it's like oh yeah that's right
and part of that is because there is so
much going on but that's that's part of
the fun that's part of the comedy all
these crazy kind of stories that you
fingers just throw away jokes and come
in at the end and make for the
really crazy climax my wife is watching
TV upstairs if you hear like walking
around and stuff but yeah and I think
that best part of the funk is this is
really a screwball comedy with stunts
you know and sci-fi talk yeah and I
think that's really cool what's cute I
don't know anyways ever seen this we're
there's a great like screwball comedy
from was at the late 70s mid 70s called
what's up doc yeah brilliant comedy it's
don't let the fact astride yes it will
usually movie that I can actually stand
Barbara Streisand in media only movie I
don't like really anything and curcumin
is hilarious and the whole ending of
that movie as this car chase through the
streets of San Francisco where half the
locations yeah it's in its three like
three or four different groups each
fighting over different bags that has
different sort of treasures and then and
nobody knows which is the right bag and
that the ending to this film so reminded
me of that where it's like they're all
after this thing and the thing just the
MacGuffin just gets tossed from one
person to the other and lay it I don't
know I just thought it was brilliant I
don't know it was an intentional homage
but it just means really I don't like it
yeah feeling it right down to the go in
the water
we're gonna make I don't think we're
gonna make it but no this movie I I just
love the characters everybody has
chemistry like I'm sorry this like will
wipe the shit stain of Jurassic Park
fallen Kingdom for my friend because
like where those characters had zero
chemistry everybody here has great
chemistry yeah I I totally buy it I'm
like actually I didn't I didn't hate the
child actress and fallen Kingdom but I
thought the character was written
terribly I even like the kids in this
movie like it does it's freakin adorable
yeah the kids adorable like this all the
characters are adorable playing off each
other every person in this film is a
scene stealer like every time they come
on boy he totally stole that scene the
number oh she totally stole this
oh she totally stole that seeing like
everybody is so good at it yeah if I had
to get to any I mean it's not even like
problems is again I guess it's more kind
of nitpicking because the one issue I
was having is that I get big shock for a
Marvel film the villains seem like a
little weak but as you see us it plays
into everything it's like again that's
there's so many stories going on where
it's like she's just one of the stories
which is know what that is funny and
that's entertaining and it's like is it
cool but it's like what been nice if
there's any more focus I would have
liked yeah because he cuz I will say
Michael Douglas has a couple throwaway
lines are like ah they they fed this
character B s that really didn't have
something that's like well there's more
to this story what isn't the movie tell
us instead of just but it's so that was
just like I'm honest II okay the villain
didn't bother me this time for a Marvel
movie because it's just not that epic mm
it's just so more about scientists doing
scientific key things to bring back
people that the villains like it just
all kind of tied together like you
didn't need a super villain villain like
that the villain in this she can like
she does this thing where she like
phases by like putting her hand through
them and I'm just like I saw the flash
um on CW I know how it works like it's
like well I this is old news and her
costume looks like if you cross like
spider-gwen with Assassin's Creed and
the sand people from star
it's a cool suit but nothing about it
screams originality to me so I'm just
like okay it was really more about the
character I'm like alright she's an
interesting character like like Joe
suggesting it mom yeah I feel like I
could have learned a little more but it
wasn't like it was the worst Marvel
villain ever I kind of felt like no I I
don't know I'm glad it wasn't a fan O's
or like I'm just you know she seems to
come out of nowhere there's suddenly
this backstory and it's like it's not
bad you know but it's like oh it's like
I I really matter it kind of wanted more
it's like what's up doc where it's just
like just another one in the pile of
people chasing after a MacGuffin like
yeah and that's why it kind of worked it
kind of worked for me in that sense yes
that's why it took me a min
because at first I'm like well I mean
this character is interesting but man
she's been gone for a while we're not
really focusing much on her and then
when you kind of see what's happening at
the end of what they're doing is kind of
like okay now I see but it's like I
would like to know more about her but
again with these Marvel films the
endings always kind of indicate you
might you actually might there's an
opening that maybe more can be done with
this character and another character in
this who who I found very interesting
that that's pushed a little to the side
but again because of the way these films
are structured it's like you might get
more of them they might come back I hope
they do because I feel like you know I
know why they were underutilized in this
it's like the powers are cool and
everything but the character herself and
I feel like you can do more with this
character I hope they do they're filling
up that they it felt really comic book
II but yeah kind of in that side story
where where you get a lot of those
villains in comic books or it's just
like we're not we're not the a-list
villain here you know this is kind of a
side story or we're you know so I
but butts in a film that already kind of
feels like a sides yes by they're just
works enough like it just sort of works
its way through any twists or surprises
you can see come in there's no there's
no surprise in this man it's it's really
about having fun yeah there's not a
single twist breaker burger
well there's one okay so this is the one
nothing gets the movie at all but this
is kind of my crossroads my personal
crossroads because Michael Douglas for a
long time said when they do ant-man to I
want my wife to play the wasps and what
captors he has Jones to play the Lost me
I'm just thinking that's like when those
beautiful women the world it's just yes
yes I think she's great at you and
everything can't even see the Jones but
then they they threw me for a loop
yeah yeah yeah yeah they show the person
is gonna play the wasp and like oh it's
not Catherine zeta-jones but it turns
out it's actually the first woman the
first woman as a kid I openly said I
have a crush on special 5 Catwoman
herself yeah and she walks in the
opening she looks like oh no they Selina
Kyle okay okay I'm not gonna lie like
you know I think if people watch our
reviews that I'm not all up on this like
CGI younger like
what yeah rogue one Leia look that was
garbage like it looked terrible I'm
sorry it looks you look like a
plasticine china doll oh I'll give it
this in this movie i sat there for like
about a good 30 seconds I'm like oh
sweet it's Michelle Pfeiffer and she's
looking good suddenly I was like wait oh
yeah cuz she looks like Batman Returns
Selina Kyle in the beginning of this
film but like it
I'll give them credit like once I once I
caught on I was like oh yeah I'm just
like alright I can see in that but
they'd the best job in this movie they
did they did on her you said there's a
scene where good - I thought he looked
alright they still have them in the dark
though - thanks I'm really I'm really
torn because like they still I
understand they have to do it cuz you're
never gonna be able to advance the
technology without constantly trying so
I get that they have to do it but it
still just looks like a really good ps4
game where it's just like oh yeah that's
cool they like mocap some actors face
and like that it's just still too
uncanny valley for me there are a couple
of moments like they caught like they
got her eyes down like crazy I'm just
like it's Celina and the fact that's my
heart you don't have to replicate too
much no but I mean she's got like these
fascinating eyes that's why she was a
perfect Catwoman but that's kind of a
made of funny - is I felt like she kind
of was acting like Selina Kyle in
beginning I was like this would have
been hilarious if it was just so mean
I'm falling asleep I'm falling asleep
yeah she's like acting crazy I'm just
like this would be amazing if she's just
having like a total breakdown but no she
she's good if you ask me like give me
like a list of most underrated actresses
unjust like Michelle Pfeiffer's in that
list I just think she's gravy or
anything I feel like she I feel like she
gets to credit most people know who
Michelle Pfeiffer now I feel like she
gets credit but I feel like sometimes
she's just kind of forgot about well cuz
everybody goes with like you know giant
name actresses
so I I don't know I feel like sometimes
she doesn't get enough credit I mean
she's had a line line for a little bit
but she's coming back another project
she's wonderful in them was it applies
SR in that man just like so good but
yeah it's one of those things where it's
like Alassane is fine cuz they also do
the same thing with Laurence Fishburne
they make him younger again for the most
part done pretty good
but it's funny because they're motion
capturing him and make him younger how
he looks now you know so he's kind of a
wave even though yeah weird the cowboy
Curtis day ya know it looks like when he
was younger so it's yeah seeing this
younger alternate version of him just a
little pudgy ER we have white hairs no
it's it's good it just it still sticks
effort we're just not there yet and I'm
like I don't know like I felt it felt
less intrusive here than in rogue one
where I honestly felt there was a lot of
hubris to that and I feel they way
overplayed their hand to that movie and
this this one I'm just like alright I'll
give you your few scenes the Tarkin
though and Leia and Moreau and I'm just
like no there's only one scene in this I
thought because I'm asking myself if if
I didn't know what they really look like
it's that what I catch on that this was
CG I don't know I would have except for
one scene where it's a point it's a POV
shot and Pfeiffer looks in the mirror
and sees herself and that looked really
weird that's the one where I'm like that
was I that that Mel's a little a little
goofy but the most pros done pretty well
and nothing probably looked as good as
the Kurt Russell one in guardians to I
think that's probably the most solid one
but but this look pretty pretty damn
good so yeah I mean for me the what I
love about this series is that on top of
the characters being great on top of it
I care about the character yeah like I
really like and on top of it just
totally absorbing that it's a side story
it having fun as hell with it I mean
just totally having fun good nose it is
like thor ragnarok did the same thing
it's like okay we're done telling you
know this giant super epic like that was
kind of there but it's also like all
right let's get goofy yeah like you know
but but also
like I said the action with the idea
that they're big they're small they're
big they're small they have the same
power and in fact it's magnified like
their punches can be even more when
they're smaller I mean it's like that's
such a great idea and I feel like you
know we're talk about technology to make
them look younger it's like technology
is there with making these action
sequences just amazing like you could
not do these action sequences like 30
years ago and I think that that's
something with a CG finish out of years
ago we add honey I Shrunk the Kids
you know which I was getting a few
callbacks to when you see the big ants
that's tough yeah that movie I hate to
say it it does there is a dated quality
to it now even though they're practical
effects I'm just like yeah like this is
like this may be an area where CGI is
pretty damn oh yeah no it's not freaking
and the CGI is everywhere we can't act
like oh if you want like an example of
where CGI works I think this movie is a
perfect example because they embrace the
the comic book nature of it it's
brightly colored you know it's it's kind
of goofy there's like a plastic quality
to it and the shrinkie the pill thing I
killed me every time they did it you
know because this building is tossed
around everywhere and again it's like
because it's a comic-book movie they can
get away with this bomb thinking like if
this was any kind of real life
everything in that lab would be
destroyed well it's got a handle bar
that you pull out like a piece of
luggage and near the end of my birthday
they like turn it back to regular size
got this giant office with his giant
handle bar like it's a suitcase like
sticking up 200 feet the air you know
what's so fun about this movie when you
really think about it there's an
technically one villain in this but
please can't to the side he's got like
this gangster guy there's none it's not
really an effective there's not really
technically any villains in this it's
just you had trying to get stuff and I'm
like what I liked about it
there's no fan OHS there was no like and
you know this is what I want this is
what I like about like just Marvel in
general recently said gave me a little
bit of everything we had your
socio-political commentary with a great
villain with
Black Panther then we had your super
epic like infinity war that got all dark
at the end and then there's just ant-man
yeah and when it's all said and done the
ant man's my favorite like it's just
like I'm it's just dumb comic book you
know yeah um the play pan that was
really freaking good to see to me is
more advanced I think a baby war is more
than one I'm just like ah that was
really good but like yeah I'm I'm coming
with you I feel like we might test 10
I'd be my top 5 yeah but now that I've
got this it might be shove down the 6
but it yeah I don't know like this is
these are the type of comic book movies
I live for and it's like some papers ago
this is a waste of time I like fun don't
see it sitting for the epic but I mean
like if you if you see the trailer any
like that looks like a lot of fun that's
what you're gonna get man though okay
the one there's two things about the
trailer I'll point out right now that
just just in terms of the only
disappointment I can connect to it what
is that the end credits scene the one
after the credits don't stay for it it's
in the trailer okay if there's an Essene
you didn't see in the trailer that
that's gonna be don't stay for the whole
end credits stay for the middle one yeah
the middle one way to go even faster go
through the cast and then there'll be
the middle one which even then we call
no we call we immediately we're like
this is gonna happen aren't we smart but
what we really did do a quick little
spoiler thing at the very end of this
okay yeah we'll just say we'll say
goodbye and then if you want to stick
around for like the one or two spoilers
I was talking about and say goodbye so
so yeah there was that and then the
other thing is there's one line in the
trailer where again this was purely to
sell the movie it's like and you got
this chick with like this go soon and
she she wants to take over the world or
whatever a that lines not in the movie
be if it was it was clearly just thrown
in so they go get in the trailer cuz
that's not the villain all like Oh which
I'm glad honestly though someone turn
off I saw in the trailer I'm like oh
like we're doing this but I'm glad
they didn't go that direction and then
the one other again this is totally
stupid it's just a dumb little nitpick
but I know she can't picked up on to the
minute she's called ghost I think the
minute she pops up
first of all wasp is like you know just
way to go
I don't know where it went I'm like well
this way that she's saying it and then
there was where she has like you know
she's got Michael Douglas this ghost
character and said you know give me that
whatever and then he's there and Michael
Douglas is like he took to the lab yeah
no I said then I said that loud I was
like he that was a what do you mind
indistinct feminine villain trying to
somehow make you think it was a dude and
I'm like from the very for a second I'm
like who's this girl
well ya know what and they don't even do
like whatever the dumbass twists where
it's like she takes off it's like it's a
woman like it that nobody's like that's
a woman like nobody is like why have
that it's clear she's got breasts it's
clear she has like a feminine figure and
like and the male voice sounds like a
woman yeah so it's like it was very uh
yeah no no no it could be a guy you
never know like yeah we count let's eat
you're like like the shock would be if
it was a guy I like the side characters
too but maybe because coming off a
fallen Kingdom where I fucking hated the
size care I'm like I just got done
watching Brad Jones is review fallen
Kingdom I think he and I I didn't
mention the side character as much but
yeah that one guy with the suntan lotion
all the time well I don't know I thought
we brought up a couple times more but
you know like the side characters and
this is like I like them all like yeah
the one that almost almost got to an
annoying degree was that Lewis guy like
he almost yeah there's one - whoa what a
walk a fine line but it was also than
done I actually laughed more than I went
out here yeah no I thank you like women
I liked them better in this movie that I
think the previous and the other two
guys yeah yeah but you guys are great
too like they improve to like I I think
I like all three of them better in this
one when the one guy
starts like saying The Legend of what he
thinks she is and that it never comes
Vallecano tsubame the Baba Yaga Baba
Yaga and like the music goes really
serious in just every place quiet and
listens to a story and then just goes
back to the film and it never comes ever
comes back I'm like that is a perfect
joke I thought that was gonna be the
character's name maybe it's gonna be
Baba Yaga uh cuz like I was like are
they really just never gonna go back to
them they never did it was I thought
that was I thought that was amazing
um I think I thought the the quantum
realm or whatever was really cool
looking ahead that dr. strange
kaleidoscope quality oh we saw a little
bit on the first one we saw it in the
first I like I like it here again I know
this is this is my kind of comic query
then science
technobabble ridiculous shit giant ants
like it's just a lie this is this is the
Marvel Comics I registered shot well I
like to again you could can't tie it
into the uniqueness of kind of Marvel
Comics but there's a scene where
Pfeiffer's character for a short bit
takes over Paul Rudd's
body and he has to act like a loving
wife and mother too you know her husband
is one of its Titans ghosts and it's one
of those things where it's it's really
funny but I was invested in the romances
I was invested in him raising his
daughter I was like I just it's a
strange movie where I'm like in all of
the family and friendship themes and
that I was really interested yes I
really like these characters and that's
something many comic book movies don't
always good did you see no this honestly
this in a weird way this feels more like
what DC does like on tv I guess feels
like kind of The CW shows like you know
whatever you feel awful
it does have drama - but it's I want
anything nuts in that supergirls to give
you that this felt like the flash kana
see it was very much like the flash with
what the villain could do so yeah they
kind of flash good I liked the flash
which I always thought that the TV
version of the flash that they're
running now kind of reminds me of just
like oh this feels kind of like
spider-man so goes full circle I don't
know so yeah if if you like these kind
of smaller you know they're still
impressive the actions cool and
everything but you know what I mean not
the grand epic movies just just these
fun kind of beat them up action
superhero movies with a lot of good
laughs yeah with a lot of land that's a
lot of humor III think you'll why not as
good as the Stan Lee watcher cameo but a
cameo that might be my second favorite
yeah yeah probably my second I mean we
couldn't stop laughing
these may be my first yeah like it's
like everyday always go look at hahaha
Stan Lee it was like a but this one just
had me just woman in the huh this was
the x-men in Deadpool to see where I had
to like just control myself after happen
cuz we'll talk about that in the spoiler
yeah so yeah so like I said we won't do
a spoiler corner we're just gonna you
know like say goodbye go see it whatever
and we'll just talk a little bit at the
Xers not really too much to talk about
so yeah if you're interested in seeing
it to see it I think you'll have fun
it's just a nice fun little Marvel movie
and I totally recommend it I had it like
again it wiped the stain of falling
Kingdom from my brain so if you look at
the trailer and thinks it looks at
anything it looks stupid you're deaf it
gets to but it is stupid but it's stupid
fun it's just it's just so much I think
the trailers sold pretty much what
you're gonna yeah exacting for that
you're gonna love it
so speaking of trailers am I the only
one who thinks that Meg movies should
have been called Chomp Chomp I was like
the first time it said Chomp I'm like
please say that yeah I was just like
it's all know the variance is the meg
and I'm just like hey shut up Meg okay -
but shut up no chug the Meg's is stupid
template the seafloor can be called
Chomp Chomp would have been amazing cuz
you got jaws and then charming yeah
that'd be the sequel yeah you make a
sequel call a child so that movie looks
awful
beautiful yeah we'll see if it's buna we
all were just awful I might see that
that looks like fun bad so guys that's
about a we're gonna go into spoilers
here so if you don't want to see them
just go see the movie and tell us we
think by bo boy spoilers okay fam oh
Santa
who's that Freddie died okay so he goes
in it's just like okay like like get
this stuff in the other three are just
again we will remain on the outside the
second like ant-man disappears I'm like
and they all vanish because of a nose
almost simultaneously audience OH
and I'm just like how did you not see
that coming oh how did you not see that
coming
like I'm just like we called it the
second we said yeah but ever it is like
in chocolate no duh I think like that
they're playing this rolling stone
review on the trailers now that's like
the Rolling Stone says the ending will
blow your mind and I was actually
thinking maybe the Shelf item was gonna
be a villain cuz she says like things
change when you're in this realm and
stuff I thought she was gonna turn into
a bear like humming all are they doing
this no because it wasn't odd seems like
things change and you you turn to me and
said she's gonna be a villain I'm like I
don't think so but but but then I'm just
like oh they did that because I go she's
evolved and now she can just magically
fix you know the problem no that was a
yeah it was fine I mean it was kind of
like haha like they all fight no no it's
fine it's fine but but it's not like I
don't know why everybody was so shot
because it was so obvious they were
gonna do that
you know a testament to the film though
because it does make you forget that you
know when this takes place baby warrants
outside then that's and then at the very
end the end playing the drums yeah
oh if people were pissed there's just
like they're like
yeah it wasn't the trail and oh the Stan
Lee cameo yeah that is my I swear to god
outside of him being the watcher that is
my favorite damn Stan that line I just
well the 60s was great but gotta pay for
it I paid for it now just the thought
cause like a part of meta part of yours
when he was like how much acid do you
think Stan Lee really did in the 60s did
he like I was like cuz I just I don't
know I just thought that was an amazing
line and I was like this is just what
you know and I was ready honestly not to
laugh because you see the car strings
with the key I'm like okay I'm gonna go
free this year yeah but it just was so
fuckin yeah that's kind of cynical
asshole critic they're like yeah okay
it's like the cameos are so expected
that there is a ho-hum quality almost of
them like you look for him it's like ha
ha there keep it very rarely are they
like hilarious like people always
applauded there was a but like it's
really 1 out of every 5 of them just
like oh no that was really true yeah
that's a good
this one is truly funny where I think
it's my second favorite cameo of all
time it's certainly the funniest one The
Watcher I think is the best one oh my
god I'm paying for it so old and just
hunched over like that just like this
kind of sad man just going I'm seeing
shit it just did like comic gold the
guy's funny it's gonna be so sad when we
will see there were no spoilers like we
knew almost any like oh the second
Laurence Fishburne shows up oh I'm like
villain like blank well especially like
when they leave when the cops yeah and
like where is he it's like oh we hate
each other's I'm like well they they're
not gonna just leave him there
patience a cannot the second chef wait
he's teaching the class I didn't know
but he was like yeah Hanks egotistical
and this Annette I'm like oh okay
villain like he's working with her like
I like that he's not either because like
I said villainous either and I really
like no I like that too I really want to
see but definitely he was not what he
seems
don't you want man said just man I
thought you were cool don't you want to
see him and ghost like either have their
own movie or just be in another movie
like The Adventures of cowboy Curtis and
ghost that was one of the best seeds
when she pops about a nowhere oh we
really had this Death of Superman thing
where he's telling the story in the
sulla and the stars are mouthing I know
it and that's all great and it's going
on and on but then the payoff of having
heard them they all go perfect for my
time nobody though is coming it just
totally comedy with are very very good
yeah so yeah that's it I say go see it
but you're watching the spoilers already
have so um that's about it we'll sit
next time Nader Michelle Pfeiffer's
still hot
you